so I want to talk about something a
little strange at the outset it will be
to some which is to talk about the
symbolism of the month of January and
its original namesake which is the god
[Music]
Janice this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to
the symbolic
world
[Applause]
[Music]
and so I don't tend to talk about pagan
symbolism so much but here I think
meditating and pondering on the Pagan
symbolism will help us understand even
some of the Christian symbolism which
appears at around this time and so
January of course is name after the god
Janice the god Janice is the god of
thresholds he is the the god of doors
the god of transition the god of in
between right and so you can understand
why the symbolism of his representation
is to show him with two faces one face
going one way the other face going the
other way and you can understand it in
different ways people will interpret it
sometimes and say you know it's the past
and the future uh sometimes you can see
Janice with three faces with one in the
middle too so it's like the past the
future and the present uh that is a good
way to understand it but you know a
better way to understand it is the
symbolism of thresholds themselves the
symbolism of the transition between two
spaces uh the ambiguity of that
transition you know there a lot of
superstitions about thresholds can be
understood that way because the
threshold is in some ways uh you know a
place that is neither inside nor outside
and it has to be
indefinite you know by its very nature
because you you know the imaginal line
between inside and outside doesn't
actually exist physically right it's
it's an imaginary boundary and that
boundary actually has no space in
physically like if you tried to actually
trace the exact line of where your house
the your house ends and begins you
wouldn't be able to find it exactly
because there's always more you can
always crush it more and more until at
some point it's actually just a virtual
line that that uh separates the inside
and the
outside that's why usually there is all
these superstitions about threshold
which is the idea that you shouldn't
step on the thresholds there are many um
there are many traditions where stepping
on the threshold of a door is is super
is bad luck and so you should always
step over the threshold in order to not
uh step into the ambiguity you could say
get trapped in Zeno's Paradox you know
uh where you can't uh actually Define
where something where the middle you
know where something starts and
something ends there's this kind of
indefinite quality about about the the
the quality of inside and outside which
is related it's so this idea of Janice
as this character that has two sides as
being the threshold as being both inside
and outside at the same time you could
say or neither you know representing
both aspects of the transition and
so sometimes Janice is represented this
way which is that you know it's usually
the same head that is on either side and
then sometimes Janice is represented
with difference between the different
heads and so there are different ways to
do it sometimes it's masculine and
feminine sometimes it is an older man
and a younger man sometimes it is in
this case for example that you see here
you see that it is a man and some kind
of Fantastical creature with horns with
pointy with pointy uh uh ears like a
fawn um and so some kind of wild
creature of the forest and so all of
these are helping you to kind of
understand that what it is it's about a
contrast so think about this image here
uh as being something like inside and
outside that is the man and the forest
the man and the monster the inside and
the outside in the same way you can see
that you could if you understand it in
time you could understand it as Youth
and age it really is about about the
this the problem of even like the you
could say the the place where past and
and future meet is ambiguous space
because it's looking in both directions
at the same time so you can understand
this this threshold or this door as
being something which is also always
there which is always something that we
kind of have access to in terms of uh
for example in terms of time but in
terms of any identity that that that has
a imaginal line that has a a difference
between the inside and outside which is
basically everything um but what's
mostly important to understand is how
this is related to this time of the year
right and so this time of the year which
is the time of around the summer around
the winter solstice the time which is
the moment when the days get the darkest
and now the day the the sunlight is
starting to appear there are all these
feasts that are kind of all cramped
together that aren't exactly at the same
time all these celebrations that are
related to the transition between the
old and the new the transition between
the darkness and the light the
transition between the old year and the
new year and so this is also part of the
symbolism of Christmas which is why I
bringing it up here it's part of of the
symbolism of Christmas because the
symbolism of Christmas is that moment
where the old Covenant and the New
Covenant is be is there's a transition
between the old Covenant and the New
Covenant and so this transition that
happens in Christmas is found reflected
in the very Solstice itself which is the
solstice is this moment of transition
between when the day gets is getting
shorter and when the day is getting
longer now you could apply that again to
the solstice if you think about how you
know when exact ex L is the moment when
the day is getting longer and the day is
getting is is getting shorter and the
day is getting longer if you try to
pinpoint that moment you're just going
to kind of dig into a virtual point or
point that actually doesn't have
quantifiable existence in time but is
this kind this this uh let's say
invisible line in between one which is
facing towards the old year which is
dark now and one which is facing to the
new year which is going going to become
light so you can understand it as if you
look at this image of The Old Man and
the new man as the the the man of
Darkness right which is the wild man and
you could say the man of Light which is
the new man the Inside Man and the
outside man see all these these images
are all related to each other uh so it
can help you kind of understand what
this symbolism is about and how it's
related to Christmas I've often said
that symbolism of Christmas is is not
straightforward the symbolism of
Christmas has in it both the light and
the dark it has the revelation of the
Messiah and the slaughter of the
Innocents it has you know the coming of
the king and the fleeing to Egypt it has
this Duality to it which is part of its
uh symbolism uh it is important to
understand how it all fits together in
terms of this this idea now it's also
related to another symbolism which you
know I'm just going to mention very
quickly uh and it was the theme of my
Patron only video this this year this
month in December which is that the
mysterious symbolism of St Nicholas and
Krampus and so this is of course the
same type of symbolism which is related
to St Nicholas and his let's say dark
strange demonic uh you know contrasting
accompaniments where on the one hand you
have the light and the dark you have the
the the Angelic the Demonic you also
have the gift the punishment you know
you can understand it as life and death
right if you think about the inside and
the outside look at this image here and
look how it's already promising
something like the contrast between the
bishop uh of light you know the the the
bishop St Nicholas and his dark uh and
kind of evil counterpart that is a wild
creature with horns similar to the way
in which the Janice figure is often
represented uh and so it can help you
understand what it is that this Duality
why this Duality is related to this time
of year and this time of transition so
you can see that you
know all of it if you want to understand
all of the symbolism of this period and
you look at the the this the symbolism
you'll see so there are two types of
symbolism January 1 the beginning of
January in the western calendar
especially in the the the northern
Europe not northern Europe but like in
France and on the continent of Europe
was circumcision day you know and I
think it's circumcision also in I mean
it's circumcision in the entire church
but circumcision day on January 1st for
Europeans in the Middle Ages was also
the Feast of fools it was also a a
carnival it was a a moment of let's say
celebration of the Flesh and cutting off
of the flesh so you you kind of have a
carnival where there's this this weird
celebration upside down and all of this
stuff and then there's a removal of the
remainder of that old world and moving
into the new world so you can understand
it again if you look at the figure of
Janice you can see that symbolism there
in in the 1 of January which is on the
one hand you have the strange you could
say forkin you know and then you also so
you have the celebration of that which
is related to Carnival which is related
to monsters which is related to these
strange ambiguous figures that live
outside that live in the forest that
dance and play the flute and and are
also you know elude and all of this kind
of symbolism related to these these
outside figures and then you have the
new man the circumcised man the one that
is on the inside and is moving towards
light towards the future towards
rectification all these types of of of
words that can help you understand what
it is that's going on and so when you
look at this symbolism you'll see why it
is always the contrast between dark and
light in all the feasts um and this
relates to the symbolism of the
transition that happens at the solstice
but that also happens at Christmas so
hope you uh you enjoy this and uh that
you will have a that you had a happy New
Year um and uh that this will help you
understand how this symbolism comes
together so thanks everybody and I'll
talk to you very very soon bye-bye